as fentanyl kills thousands of Americans
liberal activists would rather you not
hurt the feelings of murderous drug
dealers a pro-legalization Advocate
mocked all over Twitter after getting
offended by a tweet that asked whether
fentanyl dealers should get the death
penalty she responded to that by saying
this this kind of violent rhetoric
against drug workers is abhorrent most
fentanyl sellers are people who use it
as well and they are trying to survive
under the same destructive racist system
that replaced opium with morphine then
heroin then fentanyl the War on Drugs
but that's soft on drugs approach just
isn't going to cut it especially with
more Dangerous Ones emerging Biden's
drugs are declaring fentanyl laced with
animal tranquilizer as an emerging
threat
with Declaration of emerging threat
we're sending a clear message to
producers and traffickers of illicit
zalazine and illicit fentanyl that we're
going to respond quicker we're going to
match the challenge of evolution of
these drugs Supply and then we're going
to protect lives first and foremost all
right first Craig Gutfeld drug workers
is that the new um
migrants we don't call them I don't know
I don't think it's as glamorous I mean
do you go to a car worker instead of a
car dealer you know when you go to a
casino they're called dealers now
they're called sex workers not sex
sellers yeah you're absolutely right
look I think you should Target the
cartels uh while you negotiate with them
and I also think you've got to legalize
drugs I mean the only way you're gonna
have quality control uh like
prescriptions and the only way you're
going to stop fentanyl poisonings would
be to legalize these drugs which people
want the for the problem isn't with the
dealers the problem is with us right
we're the demand they're just the
supplier you oh you know what you want
you want to know who the drug dealers
are Snoop Dogg was a drug dealer Jesse
Jay-Z was a drug dealer 50 Cent was a
drug dealer Mark Wahlberg was a drug
dealer Tim Allen and you know who opened
this uh segment oh Kid Rock was a drug
dealer so I'm telling you there's a lot
of hypocrisy this is an art artificial
stance okay there's a lot of hypocrisy
from Republicans what do they love and
preach to everybody capitalism what do
they hate regulating it what is the drug
market unregulated capitalism a lot a
lot for the first rung onto that ladder
of capitalism often is drug dealing for
blacks well they so how dare you they
legalize drugs in Portland
actually and everyone's dying and
sleeping on the streets do you agree
that we should legalize drugs Judge
Jeanine
let me ask you a question what do you
think my answer is to that absolutely
not okay we can't legalize it and look
here's the drug lords working great well
no because we're not doing everything we
need to be doing arrest more people no
because they're seeking Oblivion and
what we need to do is we need to close
the border where 90 of the heroin and
pretty much all the fentanyl comes
through we need to make sure that we've
got look Joe Biden wants to sanction and
financially crippled we heard those drug
czar saying they're going to know that
we're serious are you kidding we need to
designate them as foreign terrorists so
that we can go after them the way we go
after terrorists we need to have
military strikes and I don't care if
president obedor in Mexico thinks we're
rude or thinks it's an insult that we
would consider doing this the truth is
that if you've got a hundred thousand
people dying we're in a damn War right
now and these kids are not dying because
they want to take fentanyl they're dying
because they want to take maybe an
Adderall or maybe they want to take an
oxycodone that's why you Legalize It
declared war no that's not why you
legally that's where you get the control
of it look read about Prohibition the
reason why people die during prohibition
was because the alcohol wasn't
controlled once you control pills then
you know it's an Adderall so you know
so that it's not lethal anymore fentanyl
is legal by the way prescription but
it's also legal I know it's legal drug
doctors it's also lethal on the street
but not lethal when it's prescribed well
it's not lethal when it's prescribed
yeah but here's the problem is that the
kids who don't want necessarily an
illegal drug and only want something
that's ordinary and that it's in
everybody's medicine cabinet end up
taking something because it's not
regulated because they get mixed you're
agreeing with me
the reason why people think I have had
two friends die of overdoses from
fentanyl for the same reason you're
talking about they didn't know they were
taking it yeah if it was legal that
wouldn't have happened you know what but
the truth days that people would follow
but the truth is that people are dying
of these overdoses because they don't
think that there's fentanyl in it or
they don't know that there's that I'm
gonna I will arrest my case that's what
I said you heard about this new drug I
guess it's fentanyl list with an animal
tranquilizer had you heard of that
before I have but angel dust No Angel
that's why I said no angel dust was a
horse tranquilizer that was the first uh
diversion uh to the illicit Market first
of all let me say this was a fascinating
conversation and I I tend to agree with
Greg after trillions of dollars in the
failed war and drugs I don't think that
prohibition because we haven't done the
war
just say no Satan is not
if you could take out the drug kingpins
I mean Target the cartels with military
strikes right as several prominent
Republicans are advocating then why
can't Mexico Target our gun
manufacturers because we're flooding
Mexico with guns hundreds of thousands
of guns every year that they're using in
all this violence guns don't get up and
say if we're going to go out today and
kill yourself if we're going to bomb
Mexico why don't we bomb China China is
the source of the fentanyl right I mean
you just cannot you cannot do uh all
right
that's why I think that goes we have to
at some point you have to say it's not
right I've covered I'm like the Walter
Cronkite of the drug world I've covered
every drug from 1970. I was there when
Nixon started the war on drugs it's it's
not working it doesn't work we've got to
confess it at certain point uh you know
trillions of dollars waste wasted no
controls we it's uh it's killed for
people alcohol or pot exactly it's the
easiest comparison one could make
exactly Dana P well if I'm going to go
back to the workers thing for a second
because again I do think that the
Democrats the next move will be to
unionize them and then we'll see what
the Chicago convention is like after
that but it also reminds me of you know
you can no longer say somebody is
homeless you have to say they are
unhoused and that softens the blow as if
it's supposed to be meaningful to them
and the words about what you call this
are more important than actually solving
the problem there I wish that in the
metaverse maybe Mark Zuckerberg could
work on this like in the metaverse could
there be an experiment where you do
legalize Okay and like and and actually
the way that you describe it where
people could come in look I just want to
Adderall fine are you 18 fine sign off
on it give it to that person and and see
how it goes because I agree what we're
doing is not working or maybe we're not
do I agree we're not doing enough of it
but I also think on the on the demand
side there's something that has to
happen but I want the experiment to
happen in a place where it's safe so in
the metaverse would be a good or Peru or
Amsterdam all right well when we come
back Greg is going to promise to stay
just as passionate as you've been the
entire hour it's only even two blocks I
had a huge Crackdown coming for social
media companies over Tech addiction hi
everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now